hello and welcome to this video playing
La Vie 12 okay I got my Roxy bind that's
usually good news as a 10 - farewell
them he's five I've played this move
myself and in tournament shoes in 2004
something like that 2004 something game
against Grandmaster kangas with black it
is not great but it is also not totally
terrible
okay now interesting play only push the
pawn all the way to a form that seemed
the two knights are ever certainly a bit
of a bit of a concern wow I was easily
or that was quickly decided
[Music]
yeah both recaptures look excellent
actually
[Music]
yeah I'd like to go before soonish to
push this back now yeah baby
the night the night's don't get any good
outposts very difficult to suggest any
active idea now from luck he's just
sitting there and has no idea whatsoever
it's got more time but that's the only
thing
forget before in before 96
986 I can go to a forum yeah that's true
it's okay man 97 okay cannot go to a
forum but okay then what is he doing
right so now the funny thing is that
blackest is running out of Museum he
just doesn't have any good moves well
that's good I thought I thought I had
prevented this book this is funny
of course I did not I did not
it was a bit of a stupid idea then okay
now
one idea is night a 70 on a 696 these
kind of things it's not super convincing
though and what time is running down a
little bit so I need to make a decision
now let's not promote that makes no
sense no sense to rush things
Bishop f6 I wanted to go to Bishop h6
and then d5 next b5 next trying to
invade the black position
so easier how does he handle this maybe
but there's still some issues here FEM
[Music]
activity with rugby seven still quite
annoying okay
[Music]
you know to be sound
maybe just kini eight or something
Knight f6 rupee eight is very annoying
who came now
[Music]
Knight f6 is probably working okay this
one
93 hmm I cannot take them because of
rook c1 checkmate
[Music]
let's not get mated I had the strongest
bishop d8 but I didn't have time to
figure it out so I was all stuff
probably he was quite okay there at
least after i blundered this rook c8 I
mean this position is fantastically good
for white but Queen c2 is probably
rubbish as some as somehow thought I
would prevent Lucas the aid which of
course I didn't
now this position is gradient more space
better pieces to bishops all the things
you want and I should just keep the
tension somewhere looks it always looks
good this is what the engine is coming
and now black has to make a move which
is not easy and you're entirely passive
yeah Queen c2 is Audion
I simply simply had a blackout yeah and
now he's definitely ok I thought I
thought the same during the game 5 I
find it a bit shocking f5 why does that
work I would think I can take a knight
f6 wow that's a very inhuman solution
yeah this is some lots of things are
hanging ok so I mean not worse or
anything but I'm not better
Edom ok but I think what he did is not
bad
he's completely ok
now he's six probably not so much Bishop
f6 is okay and black is okay he went
east six and now Luke a5 is just
flat-out winning really oh that's
actually very nice that's very nice
okay I'm threatening mate yeah rook
basically made you so King g8 check now
if he goes night evade I go only five
this is very nice
yeah Bishop takes Knight takes pawn
takes Bishop h6 made and yeah
if he goes Bishop f8 immediately I go
here and now this threat is totally
decisive
yep it's nice if he now moves the score
I can just take him like this yeah so
that was that would have been very nice
okay I played rugby seven which keeps Oh
Luke c7 here interesting because now
King g8 is 97 he cannot even go King g8
nice nice and this it's very nice for me
as well because I'm threatening this
idea okay okay so now he's okay again
Lucas is 795 yeah this is probably
losing you're not c5 Knight e5 still
holds it
[Music]
you know I can check him a couple of
times but it doesn't lead anywhere
okay plate 95 Bishop a4 8 the original 8
blunders the Bishop but what are you
doing here these six is hanging right
here this wins yeah now I only had to
check the major don't don't do anything
stupid that's made so I took first 5 and
now Bishop the 8th no I had to wait him
and now this nice rook c7 made decided
so there are a couple of interesting
technical points down and then quite
nice thanks a lot for watching